así como su despeinado cabello rubio no
pasa inadvertido su estilo político
tampoco boris johnson es una de las
caras más reconocidas del reino unido-
graduado de it on jan y oxford los casos
de transgresión de las reglas lo han
perseguido en sus carreras paralelas
tanto como periodista como político el
'times' lo despidió por inventar una
cita antes de ser enviado a bruselas
para trabajar en el 'daily telegraph' el
mismo diario que lo puso en el ojo del
huracán por las fiestas celebradas en
downing street durante el confinamiento
por la pandemia de kobe de 19
de este artículos contra la unión
europea durante años desde bruselas en
su libro friends borders and consumer
publicado en 2001 señaló que la
membresía del reino unido- en el bloque
comunitario le trajo beneficios
palpables al país 19 años después se
graduaría como el premier que vio a
reino unido- separarse de este grupo de
países
inseguro de europa johnson entro en el
mundo de la política como diputado siete
años después como alcalde de londres su
nombre se volvió reconocido su siguiente
paso fue convertirse en activista
durante el referendo a favor del
prestige
johnson se posicionó como una
alternativa al conservatismo pro europeo
de david cameron con la esperanza de
reemplazarlo como primer ministro pero
aún no era su momento feliz amey
consiguió subir al cargo y lo nombró
subsecretario de relaciones exteriores
incluso como el principal diplomático
del reino unido johnson fue acusado de
hacer comentarios racistas y cometer
errores garrafales como sugerir que el
entonces presidente de eeuu barack obama
tenía una antipatía ancestral con el
reino unido debido a su herencia keniana
boris johnson llegó al poder en 2019 con
la promesa de asegurar la salida del
reino unido- de la unión europea
y aunque logró hacerlo en diciembre de
2020 sus escándalos fueron más visibles
johnson y su personal se burlaron
repetidamente de las estrictas
restricciones que ellos mismos
impusieron a la nación durante la
pandemia en una serie de eventos
difíciles de justificar y que lo
pusieron sobre las cuerdas repetidas
veces